okay I I will always be in favor of a
delay because I've seen dude the the
amount of the the state that Halo
infinite launching is so unacceptable
like that I I really can't I I really
can't believe
like how mismanaged that project was
given how important that that that IP is
um
the campaign was fine it's messy bro
it's a frustrating thing because like
that's it's like a you play you play
Halo infinite it's like this is actually
a great game but it's like damn If Only
They had just given in that extra time
so they could have landed the way it
should have and that game's not really I
I don't see it really recovering ever
irreparable damage
I heard you know season of the Fall yeah
whatever